visual effects can bring our wildest
imaginations to life now more than ever
in fact it almost feels like it's easy
except recently i saw a shot that blew
my mind
[Music]
no it's not the dino
we've been able to do dinosaurs for like
30 years now no it was the water
caustics on his back
the way light concentrates into these
patterns of light is something we
actually see every single day but is
actually one of the hardest things to do
in all of cgi that's why in this video
we're going to be diving deep into how
caustics work and why everything is
alive
holy crap did i just nail it
actually what is the definition of the
word caustic
definition says able to burn or corrode
organic okay that can't possibly be it
sarcastic in a scathing and bitter way i
don't think that's also it
that was stupid and a waste of time a
caustic is essentially the concentrated
patterns of light you get after the
light passes through stuff like glass
but you see them all the time and you
probably don't even realize look at that
costume
oh what look at that costume right there
[Music]
there are lots of other examples in
movies and shows throughout the years it
makes for a very cool looking set
caustics are a physical phenomenon which
means that they can be simulated now
simulation tools have gotten better
faster and easier to use over time we
can pretty much simulate most things you
know we got smoke and fire we got liquid
water simulations we got ragdoll physics
rigid body dynamics however it's easy to
forget the most common thing that
artists simulate light because rendering
engines literally simulate how light
interacts with the environment in the
world there's a bunch of different
rendering engines out there and all of
them handle light rendering a little bit
differently
[Music]
the way light works in reality is pretty
straightforward a light source emits
photons that bounce around an
environment before landing in your
eyeballs or camera the brightness and
color of these photons are directly
changed by the materials they bounce off
of so when they eventually land in your
eyes they form an image rendering
engines try to replicate this concept by
tracing the paths of those photons but
instead of measuring them from the light
source to the camera they are usually
traced in reverse from the camera back
to the original light source if array
makes it all the way to the light then
you get the color and brightness
information for any given pixel and this
is called path tracing if the light
simulation was not limited in this way
then the computer would attempt to
simulate the infinite number of light
rays and bounces that propagate in
reality which would literally take
forever
so if caustics are just a phenomenon of
light then i should be able to render it
right
okay time to render some caustics let's
do this i just made a simple little
scene here got a donut got a cylinder
got a little blobby sphere i have them
coming out of the ground here look at
this
so i'm gonna see if i can get these to
render
caustics
i've got it rendering out to 16 000
samples right now
we're getting something
we're getting something we're getting
some gossips
why is this taking forever
a little longer than a few minutes later
oh my god it's still nowhere close to
finishing
why is this taking forever
i give up i don't get it
why are caustics so hard to render
costumes have been changed
oh yeah this is jules erbach the founder
and ceo of otoy which is responsible for
octane render my favorite render engine
hostics is an art form it's been
something people avoided classics that
they used to avoid you know skid there
is a reason why classics are difficult
and that's because you're you know when
you're doing typical rendering if you
think of light like water you're trying
to catch a bucket of light and you cast
a wide net and ultimately you get a
result that's averaged out and it's
maybe a little noisy but it worked
if you're trying to render
something like a laser or something for
magnifying glass all that light think of
it being sort of like put through a
complex nozzle and all of a sudden those
paths individually need to be traced you
know that's where classics become really
hard
in order to just you know follow through
the rules of physics and light if you do
sample things you know caustics are the
things that you need a lot more samples
to get the actual result you just have
to calculate a lot more individual
photons versus just approximating an
average of how light spreads throughout
the scene and you know it's it's one of
the more expensive parts of the red ring
equation you know you could make it put
a gobo right in front of a light and
call back mustangs fake it with gobos
okay great
what's a gobo
a gobo is a type of screen that you
actually put in front of a spotlight to
project a shaped shadow of something
like say blinds or ferns or trees leaves
that sort of thing and since that is
something i can do practically i can
replicate it digitally as well instead
of using say ferns or blinds or whatever
random shapes you have you can
substitute any sort of black and white
image in that you want or perhaps
caustics and you can take that another
step further by using an actual texture
image sequence a video file you can
literally record footage of the caustics
at the bottom of a pool clamp it down
into a black and white image that can
now be our projected light shape
it just happens to look like real
caustics
if you're to simulate that for real with
an actual surface of water the light has
to then bend the correct way and that
takes so much longer to calculate it's
the same exact principle of using a real
gobo but it's so much cheaper to render
this is generally the way it's done
across the board in visual effects
because doing it for real kind of just
is not an option it takes too long
so now i'm wondering if i can replicate
that shot from prehistoric planet by
using fake gobos
if you remember the jurassic park video
we did last fall we have a nice high
quality 3d model of a t-rex and these
are the results
look at the patterns of light on the
t-rex's back and how it actually falls
off the same way it does in prehistoric
planets i'm now convinced that this is
exactly how they did it in prehistoric
planet all of these caustics are
probably the result of gobos
but i'm not satisfied faking these
caustics with gobos i want to do them
for real and luckily there's a brand new
render kernel called photon tracer
it turns out that there's you know more
sophisticated ways of rendering plastics
and that's what the photon tracer does
it's doing it in a way that gets you to
the results that would take million
times longer faster it is traditionally
full-time mapping with path guiding all
these things and you end up with
something that solves all these problems
no compromises full speed full quality
it's not instantaneous i mean but it's
really fast like a thousand times faster
if you turn that off and you pitch to
tap tracing it's not going to look any
different if you let it go all the way
to the same number of samples and that's
the magic of it so now that i feel that
i can actually correctly simulate
caustics in a renderer i want to put
them to the test by comparing them to
what i can film in real life
these are like the classic kinds of
caustics and if you're using the
sunlight something like this is actually
strong enough to catch things on fire
it starts getting
oh my god it's already starting to burn
fire fire fire this bee's already dead
this this bee is already oh god oh god
dude i want to have freaking spots in my
eyes now don't
ah
ren
dude you saw how quick that was you know
that's hot i know it's hot but i just
wanted to feel it
if you have a vr headset this is exactly
why you should not put it down with the
lenses facing up because the sun will
literally melt the screen
so i got the idea to try to actually
replicate moving the magnifying glass in
real life so that i can replicate it
digitally to see if the caustics match
up to do so i'm literally going to use
my phone as a motion capture device
literally tracking the position and
rotation of this magnifying glass here
do the rendered caustics match the real
caustics we'll find out here in a moment
i wanted to take a quick break from all
of this rendering talk to tell you about
our sponsor squarespace you know what's
nice about squarespace you don't have to
know anything about making a website
because they've got so many
award-winning templates right for you
right now if you're running a business
it's imperative you know all of the
analytics and data throughpoint through
your website and guess what squarespace
gives you all of that control and all of
the data you could possibly want at your
fingertips ready to go and if you want
to take that a step further with
multiple contributors you can have
multiple different people contributing
to your website all with different
permissions set by you also i understand
having to post across multiple different
social media accounts well guess what
you post your website it'll
automatically post to all of your social
media accounts all at once and i know
what you might be thinking if
squarespace is making my website do they
own the website no everything you put
out you own you know that for a fact if
you got videos that you want to put on
your website you can optimize the
loading speeds of all of it by using
their video block system to make sure
that everything loads exactly when it's
needed why do i do hand gestures i
cannot talk without my hands anyway
thanks again to squarespace for
sponsoring the show they've been our
sponsors for a very long time and i
always appreciate the ogs in the sponsor
space so if you want to start your own
website whether it's for starting your
own business or sharing your artwork
head to squarespace.com corridor crew
and you will get 10 off your first
website or domain now for some caustics
but here's the thing i can't replicate
this magnifying glass unless i actually
replicate the properties of the glass
itself index of refraction dispersion
these are things that i need to put into
the material in order to actually get
the same type of caustic
and lo and behold i'm actually
replicating the real caustics pretty
accurately there's some small
differences here probably because i
didn't model the lens exactly the same
but i mean this is pretty close
especially when you see when i move the
magnifying glass forward and back like
that the way the light inverts
that is pretty interesting the fact that
i was able to replicate that for real
man this has inspired me now that i know
that caustics are literally as easy as
hitting the check mark on the renderer
it's like i kind of want to go crazy
what sort of caustics can i make
so i've become obsessed i have started
rendering out a bunch of different
examples just having fun with it it's
super easy to set up caustics but
there's still a problem
caustics are still
very slow to render
this one shot right here took 100 hours
to render
at 720p it took 100 hours to render on a
computer with a 30 90 in it that's a
long time to render but think about it
this way if i wasn't using this it would
have taken 100 000 hours to render how
long is that hey siri 100 000 hours in
years
100 000 hours is 11.41 years
i guess a hundred hours isn't that bad
but i cannot stop thinking about that
prehistoric planet shot like i feel like
i can probably now actually simulate
those caustics for real and that will
give us an opportunity to directly
compare the gobo caustics to the real
physically simulated caustics and this
might actually show us whether it's
worth it to simulate those caustics for
real now so check this out i've got x
particles it's great and they have a
super simple ocean surface thing
technically this ocean surface is not
simulated it's based off of a noise map
but the light passing through it is
simulated so i'm going to call this real
i mean look at that
it's real it's real i'm actually
simulating real caustics on the back of
a dinosaur i feel like i achieved
something here now let's actually
compare the results
right away i think the first thing i
noticed is that the fake caustics are a
little too consistent if we ignore the
scale here for a moment i think the
simulated caustics have a slightly
different off look at the intensity of
the lights at the brightest points on
each image notice how on the simulated
caustics the light actually has this
nice fall off it feels a little bit more
natural compared to say the gobo where
it's kind of just the same intensity
everywhere
but you know what
the results are pretty similar
like it's cool that these are physically
simulated and it does technically look a
little bit more real to me but
is it worth it i'm not so sure
especially when you're able to kick out
like 100 more shots than you would be to
simulate it for real so yeah it turns
out there's not really too much
difference between fake caustics and
simulated caustics i mean yes the
simulated ones are a little nicer in my
eye it's just that the difference is so
negligible it's not really even worth
worrying about so much so in fact that
we actually applied this principle in
real life i literally took the exact
same texture sequence i've been using to
make all of these fake caustics but i
put it in a real projector that we used
to project caustics onto me for the
opening shot of this video so that
opening shot has real caustics fake
caustics does it matter i keep using
this term fake but think about it all
visual effects all cgi
it's all fake i mean think about reality
you have an infinite number of light
bounces going around a scene infinite
number of substeps for all of the
simulations you see around you all the
textures are super high resolution
everything is hdr and it all runs in
real time without ever crashing
visual effects it's all a trick none of
it's real there's always some degree of
craftsmanship that is creating something
for us to live in for a brief moment in
time to escape reality to suspend our
disbelief and as long as the tricks we
employ get us there it doesn't matter
how we got there
so now that you've made it to the end of
this video and you've learned everything
that i hope you've learned from this
randomly super nerdy esoteric niche cgi
video
i want you to start considering the
trailer of avatar 2. are the caustics in
that movie faked like i've described or
did wheta go beyond and above what is
necessary by physically and accurately
simulating how light works for a movie
that takes place almost entirely
underwater when you eventually get to
check out this movie i want this to be
on your mind are the caustics physically
simulated if we can actually get wetter
to make a statement about the caustics
in the movie that would be even better
that'd be so cool if you have any ideas
for other sort of like randomly niche
cgi things that i can maybe dive into
and really get the whole picture about
it let me know in a comment down below
and maybe that'll be an upcoming video
[Music]
[Music]
you